En este video vamos a practicar más la
construcción de diagramas de Lewis e intentaremos
hacer esto para un anión cianuro. Esto es muy
interesante, ya que será la primera vez que
intentemos construir el diagrama de Lewis para un
ion, así que pausa el video e inténtalo. Muy bien,
vamos a trabajar juntos. Ya hemos visto en varios
videos que el primer paso es contar el total
de electrones de valencia con los que estamos
trabajando para asegurarnos de asignarlos todos.
Para ayudarnos con esto, vamos a observar nuestra
tabla periódica de los elementos. Ya sabemos que
el carbono tiene 1, 2, 3, 4 electrones de valencia
en su segunda capa, en su segundo periodo,
tenemos 4 electrones de valencia del carbono;
mientras que el nitrógeno tiene 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 electrones de valencia en su segunda capa, en
su segundo periodo. Entonces, los electrones de
valencia de un átomo neutro y libre de carbono y
uno de nitrógeno nos da un total de 9 electrones
de valencia. Pero todavía no hemos acabado, ya
que no tenemos una molécula neutra, es decir,
tenemos una carga negativa, es un anión, tenemos
una carga de -1. Debido a este -1 debemos pensar
que tenemos un electrón de valencia extra, por lo
tanto, agreguemos este electrón de valencia extra
por aquí. ¿Para qué hacemos esto? Bueno, esto
se debe a esta carga negativa y, por lo tanto,
trabajaremos con un total de 10 electrones
de valencia. El segundo paso es dibujar los
enlaces simples e identificar el átomo central.
Como esta vez sólo tenemos dos átomos realmente
no tenemos ninguno central, así que pongamos
el carbono por aquí y el nitrógeno por acá,
uno al lado del otro, y dibujemos un enlace
simple. Al dibujar este enlace simple hemos
asignado 2 electrones de valencia, por lo tanto,
hay 8 electrones de valencia restantes. Y ése es
el siguiente paso: asignar los electrones de
valencia restantes, así que empecemos con el
átomo más electronegativo. Intentemos
que el nitrógeno complete su octeto,
ya tenemos 2 así que vamos a asignarle 3 pares
solitarios extras de electrones, tenemos: 2, 4,
6, 8, y con esto hemos asignado 6 electrones
de valencia de estos 8 restantes. Entonces,
-6 electrones de valencia, nos quedaremos con
2 electrones de valencia para asignar, así que
démosle al carbono estos 2 electrones de valencia
de esta forma. Con esto ya hemos usado todos los
electrones de valencia. Ahora veamos qué tan feliz
está cada átomo. El nitrógeno tiene 8 electrones
de valencia a su alrededor: 2, 4, 6, 8; mientras
que el carbono tiene 4: 2 y 4. Entonces es aquí
donde debemos pensar si se requieren algunos
enlaces extras o enlaces de orden superior,
así que ¿cómo le damos al carbono más electrones
de valencia? Bueno, podemos tomar algunos de estos
pares solitarios alrededor del nitrógeno y usarlos
para convertir este enlace covalente en un enlace
de orden superior. Entonces, veamos: si tenemos
que tomar estos 2 electrones y convertirlos en un
enlace covalente. ¿Qué pasará? Bueno, voy a borrar
todo esto y a dibujar otro enlace covalente. Esta
vez el nitrógeno tiene todavía 8 electrones a
su alrededor, mientras que el carbono tiene 6,
así que podemos hacer de nuevo lo mismo. Borremos
estos 2 electrones y con ellos hagamos otro enlace
covalente. Entonces, ¿qué está pasando? Bueno, el
carbono tiene 2, 4, 6, 8 electrones de valencia a
su alrededor y el nitrógeno tiene 2, 4, 6, 8
electrones a su alrededor, así que esto se ve
bastante bien. Pero ¿ya hemos terminado? La
respuesta es no, aún no hemos representado
esta carga negativa en nuestro diagrama de Lewis.
Para hacerlo ponemos entre corchetes la molécula
entera y decimos "Oye, esta molécula tiene
una carga negativa". Y ahora hemos terminado,
hemos asignado todos nuestros electrones de
valencia, cumplimos nuestras reglas del octeto
en todos nuestros átomos que no sean el hidrógeno,
ya que, bueno, aquí no tenemos hidrógenos,
y con estos corchetes mostramos que, en efecto,
es un anión. Y ya está, hemos terminado.